大家好,
我是Jim,
這裡是AI Notebook,
這一集我們繼續上耶魯大學的賽局理論公開課,
課號ECON159,
這次上第九,
重蹈第十六塔,
講臺上還是Ben Pollack老師,
上集的答案是,
難的不是算出自己要什麼,
是算出別人會怎麼做,
這八堂課要再往前走一步,
問一個很生活的問題,
你想好的那一步,
等別人反應過來以後,
還划算嗎?別人可能會猜你,
可能會一代一代換人,
也可能站在旁邊看你出手以後才懂,
我先把答案放在前面,
難的不是眼前划算,
是長期划算,
長期的意思就是把別人所有的反應都算進去以後
最後一堂課Polak發給兩個同學
各一塊四海綿
讓他們站在走道兩端
他們都知道要丟
問題是什麼時候丟
這一題我們留到最後
先從網球場開始
Polak說Venus跟Serena在打球
Serena衝到往前
球來到Venus這邊
Venus要把球從Serena旁邊打過去
只有兩條路
打她的左邊
或者打她的右邊
Serena的左邊是反手
比較弱
右邊是Venus自己最拿手的那種球
Serena也只有兩個選擇
身體先往左拼一點
或者先往右偏一點
規則很好懂
Venus打到Serena沒守著那一邊
多半得分
打到她守著的那一邊
球常常被截回來
所以你先想一下Venus該打哪邊
假設她決定打左邊
Serena猜到了
就往左偏
Venus看到她往左就改打右邊
Serena又猜到了
改往右偏
繞一圈又回到原點
這跟猜拳一模一樣
你連出三四十投
對面就會等著出步
在這一球裡
沒有任何一個固定的選擇站得住
電視上的球賽評論員最愛說
打你最強的那一邊就對了
不用管對手
Polak說
這句話聽起來很對
今天就會看到他錯在哪裡
既然固定會被等著
Venus能做的只剩一件事
不要固定
這個做法叫Mixed Strategy
中文叫混合策略
他的意思是
你不是永遠打左邊
也不是永遠打右邊
而是照一個比例去混
譬如
十球壘大概幾球打左
幾球打右
可是哪一球打哪邊
對手事先不知道
你會發現
Venus並沒有變得更會打球
他只是讓Serena
沒辦法先站好
聽起來簡單
做起來很難
因為人很不會亂數
你以為自己在亂打
其實常常有規律
Polak講了一個故事
第二次世界大戰之後
一位英國指揮官在打一場遊擊戰
Polak印象中是在馬來西亞
他兵力不夠
每天只能保護其中幾支車隊
派哪一支
絕對不能被對方猜到
他的辦法是
每天早上把一張紙條藏在一隻手裡
叫一位士官猜在哪一隻手
用這個來決定當天的安排
他知道自己的腦袋靠不住
乾脆把決定交給那張紙
混合策略有一個很重要的性質
第一次聽會有點繞
Polak用身高來講
他請三位助教站起來
說我要從他們裡面挑一組人
這組人的平均身高越高越好
我會怎麼挑
最矮的那一位先出局
他只會把平均拉低
第一個矮的也出局
最後只留最高的那一位
只有一種情況會留兩個人
就是兩個人一樣高
混合策略也是這樣
假設Venus打左邊其實比較容易得分
他就該一直打左邊
何必混
他願意兩邊混著打
唯一的理由是
兩邊給他的分數一樣高
所以這句話請你先記住
混在裡面的每一種選擇
分數一定一樣高
不然早就被踢出去了
這一集後面好幾個例子
用的都是這一句
這句話馬上就能用
而且用法有點怪
你想知道Serena會怎麼混
要看的不是Serena的分數
是Venus的分數
我們一步一步來
Venus兩邊都在打
所以兩邊給她的分數一樣高
可是Venus打左邊能拿幾分
要看Serena多長往左手
Serena往左手太多
Venus就該全打右邊
手太少
Venus就該全打左邊
只有一個剛剛好的比例
會讓Venus覺得打哪邊都一樣
那個比例就是Serena的答案
Polak在黑板上寫一個等號
解出來是
Serena Sen
次裡有六次往左偏
你想一下這件事有多怪
要算出他怎麼動
看的是你自己那一籃的分數
他不是故意要讓你打哪邊都一樣
是如果他不這樣守
你就會找到他的破綻
一直打那邊
有了這個怪方法
Polak出了一道題
Serena請了一位新教練
把反手節給練得更好
反手就是他的左邊
原本他十次裡有六次往左偏
現在他該更常往左還是更少
你的直覺大概跟很多同學一樣
那邊變強了
當然多用
Polak讓全班舉手
很多人壓多用
也有不少人乾脆不投
重新算一次
Serena往左的比例
從6氣掉到5氣
她反而少往左
為什麼
照剛剛那個怪方法
Serena怎麼守
是Venus的分數決定的
Serena反手變強
改的是Venus打左邊的拿的分數
Venus
直到妹妹反手變強了
就少打那一邊
球來的少了
Serena也不必一直守在那裡
不然把這兩股力量分開講
一股是直接的效果
我變強了
所以多用
另一股是策略上的效果
對手看到我變強
先換了打的方向
結果是後面那股比較大
只看自己強在哪裡的教練
會把Serena
交到往錯的方向守
網球的例子講完
Paulak換到棒球
棒球裡有一個動作叫倒壘
跑者趁投手投球的時候
偷偷衝向下一個壘包
成功了
離得分進一步
被抓到直接出局
有分析師做過很認真的統計
把美國職棒大聯盟跑者
站上一壘的每一次都翻出來
最後的結論是
跑者去倒壘
跟乖乖待在壘上
對比賽的影響差不多
所以他們說
速度被高估了
Paulak就說
這個數字我們不用查資料就知道
它一定長這樣
你還記得那句話嗎
混在裡面的
分數一樣高
職業跑者本來就在混
有時候跑有時候不跑
連投手都猜不到
兩種都在用
兩種的效果本來就該一樣
要是跑明顯比較好
他就會每次都跑
所以那份統計沒有發現速度沒用
它只是證明了跑者真的在混
那速度的價值
跑到哪裡去了
答案在下一棒身上
Pollock在教室裡找到一位
耶魯棒球隊的投手
叫Chris
問他
一雷站著一個跑得快的人
你會有什麼不一樣
Chris說至少三件事
想辦法把球傳回一壘牽制他
把球更快送到本壘
必要的時候故意把球偷偏
讓補手好傳
Polak再補一句
投手還會多投直球
因為直球最快到補手手上
這些事情
每一件都有代價
為了快
投手的放掉平常那一套
比較大的準備動作
直球又比變化球好打
打者等等就是這種球
把整串連起來看
快腿站上一壘
投手分心
下一棒就比較好打
所以快腿的價值
不在他自己倒壘的數字裡
在他後面那一棒的打擊率裡
那份統計沒有算錯
是看錯的地方
這一段我第一次看也愣了一下
那份統計只盯著跑者自己那一格
沒看到那一格讓投手跟下一棒變成什麼樣子
網球跟棒球裡
選手是真的在變換出手
可是混合策略一定是有人在亂數嗎
Paul Rack用一對約會的同學來回答
Nina跟David
上集他們約在電影院
忘了講好看哪一部
這次又要出門了
要選的是去果園摘蘋果
還是去夜滷劇場看戲
妮娜比較想摘蘋果
David比較想看戲
可是兩個人都寧可待在一起
去自己比較不喜歡的地方
也比一個人好
結果他們又忘了先講好
這時候
兩個人都只能猜
對方會去哪
而且都有點偏向自己喜歡的地方
Paulak算出來
就次理由
他們根本碰不到面
比一半還多
可是這兩個人並沒有在丟銅板
Paulak說
這裡的比例
比較好的讀法是
別人心裡對你的猜測
這是混合策略的第二種讀法
David覺得妮娜大概會去果園
這個猜測
就是Nina的混合策略
你不必真的亂數
別人心裡那個比例
就已經在決定結果了
這個讀法
請你先放著
到最後講名聲的時候
他會回來
那如果連猜都沒人在猜呢
那天剛好是家長週末
教室裡坐著不少爸媽
Polack
就拿報稅來講
報稅的人可以老實填
也可以少報一點
查賬的一方可以查你
也可以不查
我們先把四種結果用話講一遍
老實填又沒被查
相安無事
老實填卻被查
查賬的人百花利器
少報又被查到
罰得很重
還可能吃上官司
掃報又沒被查
就多留了一筆錢
現在看兩邊怎麼跟著改
大家都老實
查賬的就懶得查
沒人查
掃報就很划算
掃報的人一多
查賬又變得很值得
又是一圈猜拳
只是這一次
繞圈的是一整群人
算出來的結果是
每三個人裡有二個老實繳稅
這就是混合策略的第三種讀法
沒有人在丟銅板
也不是誰在猜誰
是一大群人裡
有的人這樣做
有的人那樣做
比例就停在那裡
有了這張表
Polak做了一個很像政策的實驗
假設國會看不下去
決定把逃漏稅的罰金加倍
你猜老實繳稅的人會變多嗎
全班投票
多數人壓會變多
Polak還注意到
教室裡的家長都沒舉手
重新算一次
收罰的比例完全沒動
還是每三個人裡有一個
重的是查賬
查賬的次數變少了
為什麼
答案又是那句老話
混在裡面的
分數一樣高
查賬的一方也在混
有時查有時不查
所以查跟不查
對他一樣划算
能讓他覺得一樣划算的收法比例
是用他自己那張表算出來的
查一次要花多少力氣
查到了有多少收穫
國會改的
卻是報稅那邊的表
所以報稅的人也不動
查賬的人少查一點
照樣壓得住
同一個道理
也解釋了為什麼有錢人比較常被查
不是他們比較不老實
是他們少報一次賺得比較多
要多查幾次
才能壓回原來的比例
真的想讓更多人收罰
Polak說
要改的是查賬那一方的誘因
我們先停一下
把第一部分收起來
第二個問題是
對方會猜你的時候
然後你想好的那一步還划算嗎?
答案是隻要你一固定
就不划算
對面會在那裡等你
所以要混
這叫混合策略
他有三種讀法
真的在亂數
像Venus跟盜雷的跑者
別人心裡對你的猜測
像約不到的Nina跟David
還有一大群人你的比例
像報稅
三種讀法用同一句話算
混在裡面的分數一樣高
這句話帶出一個很怪的結論
你怎麼混
是對面的分數決定的
Serena反手變強
他反而掃手那一邊
罰金加重
改變的是查帳的人
如果前面哪一段沒跟上
記住這一句就夠了
你要算的不是自己那張表
是對面那張
第三種讀法特別重要
Polak在下課前說
下一堂課
他要把一大群人裡的比例這個想法
帶到一個完全不同的地方演化
到這裡為止
做選擇的都是會算的人
Polak接著問
如果根本沒有人在算呢
他說
生物學家這幾十年來
拿賽局理論研究動物的行為
做法是這樣換的
策略換成基因
分數換成能留下多少後代
做的好的做法後代多越來越多
做的差的慢慢消失
一隻螞蟻不會坐下來
想要衝出去守巢
他的做法是天生寫好的
他不會被說服
只會留下來或者消失
你可以把它想成夜市裡的攤子
很多老闆不一定算過
怎麼定價最好
可是一條街逛下來
活下來的攤子
多半是賺得到錢的
賺不到的早就收掉了
Polak自己也舉了這種例子
市場上的競爭
就像叢林裡的競爭
公司倒閉
就是基因消失
他先講清楚兩件事
他不是生物學家
而且今天的模型很陽春
假設每一隻螞蟻
都是直接複製自己
然後他對全班說
你們現在全部是螞蟻
一開始
全班都是合作的螞蟻
碰在一起
兩邊都拿到不錯的分數
後透帶一路增加
然後Polak
放進一個突變
突變的意思是
族群裡偶爾生出一小群作法跟大家不一樣的
這次的突變是幾位助教他們天生不合作
一隻叫Nick的合作螞蟻
剛好碰上助教Rahul
Nick出力
Rahul不出力
Nick什麼也沒拿到
Rahul拿到最高分
一輪一輪下去
Rahul這群越來越多
合作的螞蟻碰到他們的機會也越來越高
這裡要給一個名字
這個標準叫Evolutionary Stable
中文叫演化穩定
它的意思是
一整群都用同一種做法
少數外人帶著別的做法進來
掙不到便宜
最後自己消失
照這個標準
合作不是演化穩定
外人一進來就掙到便宜
反過來試一次
全班都不合作
放進一隻合作的土便豬叫Metal
它碰到的幾乎都是不合作的
每一次都吃虧
很快就不見了
長期留下來的是不合作
Polak的結論很直接
大自然選出來的結果
可能很糟
可是這個結論
跟你在動物節目裡看到的不一樣
獅子打獵的時候真的會合作
螞蟻窩被攻擊的時候
真的有螞蟻衝出去
模型卻說合作留不下來
到底哪裡不對
全班猜了好幾個方向
有人說不同族群之間會競爭
有人說動物會抓作弊的
Polag說有道理
可是他要的答案更簡單
他還提示
你們這個年紀每天都在想的事
最後一位同學講中了
因為模型假設的是無性生殖
真實的動物有爸爸有媽媽
基因會分到子女性類姐妹表情身上
所以真正要留下來的
不是哪一隻獅子
是那一段基因
你是一隻螞蟻
你衝出去可能會死
可是草裡很多是你的姐妹
身上有很多跟你一樣的基因
你死了
他們活下來
那段基因照樣傳下去
合作
是從親戚關係裡長出來的
我很喜歡這一段
Paul Lark先把模型講完
再親手指出他漏掉什麼
下次有人說
這是天性所以是對的
你可以先問一句
那個模型假設了什麼
演化穩定這個定義
是生物學家Maina Smith
在1971年正式寫下來的
經濟學那邊
1950年代有了納許均衡
上集講過
每個人都已經對別人做了最好的回應
沒有人想自己改
一個看基因怎麼傳
一個看人怎麼選
出發點完全不一樣
可是Polak把兩個定義攤開來對
他們幾乎是同一件事
演化穩定的做法
一定也是拿取均衡
為什麼
我們反過來想
如果某種做法不是對別人最好的回應
就代表有另一種做法更好
那種做法變成突變闖進來
就會佔到便宜
原來的做法也就不穩了
Polak說
這讓他想到17世紀
大家發現行星怎麼轉
跟時鐘怎麼走
是同一套力學
他也自己笑
說大概只有少數同學會跟他一起興奮
其他人覺得他瘋了
對我們來說這句話很有用
不會算的螞蟻最後停下來的地方
會算的人也算得到
所以第一部分那些工具
這裡照樣能用
有了演化穩定的把持
Polak先拿他量一件很日常的事
開車靠左還是靠右
你在一個大家都靠左的地方靠右開來
你活不了多久
Polak說
一個沒把旅遊書讀仔細的美國觀光客
到了英國
很快就被淘汰了
我們用他把持量一次
大家都靠左
竟然有一個靠右的
他碰到誰都要撞車
完全佔不到便宜
所以靠左是穩的
大家都靠右
進來一個靠左的
也一樣
所以兩個都穩
這帶出兩件事
第一件
世界上可以同時有
好幾種穩的習慣
英國 日本 澳洲靠左
法國 美國靠右
一點都不奇怪
第二件
不代表比較好
Polla開玩笑說
靠左看起來比較有氣質
所以他在表上
給靠左多一點分數
就算這樣一個社會
照樣可能停在靠右
而且再也改不動
因為第一個改的人
一定先吃虧
我們常聽到一句話
留下來的就是最好的
這裡剛好相反
留下來的只是沒有被推翻的
靠著靠右不用打架
可是很多動物要搶東西
Polak
記著講一個生物學家研究很久的遊戲
這個遊戲叫Hawk Dolph
中文叫英格賽局
他的意思是
同一種動物裡有兩種脾氣
英式遇到就打
鴿式遇到就讓
不是兩種鳥
要搶的東西可能是食物
可能是地盤
可能是交配的機會
我們叫他獎品
真的打起來也有代價
可能頓一條腿
甚至沒命
我們叫他傷害
Polak沒有給這兩樣填數字
就讓他們留在黑板上
等一下就會很有用
先看第一種情況
獎品比傷害大
整群都是鴿
進來一隻鷹
對面每次都讓
他每次都拿到獎品
很快就多起來
所以全是鴿站不住
整群都是鷹
進來一隻鴿
他每次都讓
什麼也拿不到
很快就消失
所以獎品夠大的時候
全部當鷹才是穩的
你看到一群動物天天打架
不一定是脾氣壞
可能只是那邊的獎品真的夠大
第二種情況比較有意思
傷害比獎品大
全部當鴿
一樣站不住
來一隻鷹就橫著走
可是全部當鷹也站不住
兩隻鷹碰在一起
一半的時候搶到獎品
一半的時候受傷
傷又比獎品重
平均下來是虧的
這時候進來一隻鴿
它拿不到獎品
可是也不會受傷
反而過得比鷹好
所以最後停下來的是
鷹跟鴿混在一起
那比例是多少
這裡用的
正是第一部分那句話
混在裡面的分數一樣高
族群裡鷹跟鴿都活得下去
代表當鷹跟當鴿
平均分數一樣
把這個等號寫下去
答案很乾淨
因的比例剛好等於獎品除以傷害
獎品越大
因越多
傷害越大
割越多
你看網球場上那個工具
搬到動物身上照樣算得出來
只是這一次混合不是誰在亂數
是一整群動物裡
有多少是因
有多少是割
就像暴碎那一群人
接下來Polak問了一個問題
我第一次聽也答錯了
假設打架的傷害變重
斷的不是腿
是整條命
整個族群平均會過得更好
還是更差
直覺會說更差
受重傷的更多了
算出來就是更好
原因是傷害一大
因的比例就掉下來
真正打起來的次數少很多
少到足夠補回每一次受的傷
打架的代價變重
架反而打得少
大家平均反而過得好一點
這個理論還有一個優點
它能被檢驗
獎品跟傷害
我們在野外看不到
可是打架的比例看得到
打架的比例一數出來
就能反推獎品跟傷害的比值
Pollack說
這件事在經濟學跟生物學裡
都有一個名字
叫識別
他的意思是
從看得到的資料
把理論裡看不到的東西算回來
可是能解釋已經看到的事還不夠
理論要厲害
得說出一件還沒人看過的事
Polec說
如果自然界真的有一場猜拳
三種做法互相剋
那用演化穩定這把尺去量
會發現沒有任何一種比例是穩的
族群不會停下來
會一圈一圈的繞
1990年代中期
一篇登在Nature期刊的論文
真的找到了
那是一種蜥蜴
它們有三種顏色
橘色的地盤很大
守著很多母蜥蜴
黃色的偷偷混進別人的地盤
找機會交配
藍色的地盤小
幾乎只收著一隻
橘色被黃色佔便宜
黃色被藍色佔便宜
藍色又被橘色佔便宜
族群的比例
正在照著模型說的在繞圈
Pollock說
這對生物學家來說
就像找到黑洞
上集結尾那場拆圈
網球場上那一圈
到這裡變成了
一整個族群的一圈
我們把第二部分也收起來
第二個問題是
如果根本沒有人在算
只是一代一代換人
哪一種做法會留下來
答案是
留下來的是
外人進來佔不到便宜的做法
這叫演化穩定
而且不會算的螞蟻停下來的地方
會算的人也算得到
所以第一部分的工具照樣能用
硬的比例就是這樣算出來的
可是這一部分也給了三個提醒
留下來的不一定好
一窩合作的螞蟻會被不合作的吃掉
留下來的不止一種
靠左靠右都穩
穩了就很難改
有時候根本停不下來
像蜥蜴一直在繞圈
我們再回到夜市
在演化里老攤子什麼也不能做
新攤子進來
佔不佔得到便宜
全看那張分數表
可是真的市場不是這樣
老闆看得到隔壁新開了一家
他可以決定要不要降價
拼一場
一旦有人看得到你的動作
看完才決定怎麼回你
整件事就換了一個樣子
這個老攤子跟新攤子
我們先放著
後面會回來
Polak拿出一頂粉紅色的帽子
這是裡面放真的錢
規則是這樣
第一個人可以放零元一塊
花三塊進帽子
然後把帽子傳給第二個人
第二個人打開看得到裡面有多少
還有兩個選擇
跟著放一樣多
兩個人一起把錢翻倍
或者直接把錢拿走
放得越多
一起翻倍的時候
這時候兩個人賺越多
被拿走的時候也虧越多
第一組 Justin放了一塊
Nate跟了一塊
換一組
Katy也放一塊
帽子從講臺一路傳到教室另一頭
沒有人動裡面的錢
Steven也跟了
兩組都沒人放 三塊
這種遊戲叫Sequential Game
中文叫序列賽局
他的意思是大家照順序動
可是重點不在誰先誰後
在後面的人看得到前面的人做了什麼
而且前面的人知道他看得到
網球是兩個人同時決定 只能猜
帽子是看了再決定
所以放錢的人得先想好
對方看到之後會怎麼做
為什麼沒人放三塊
Justin自己講得很清楚
放一塊
他跟著放比較賺
他會跟
我放三塊
他直接拿走比較賺
他一定拿走
Paulak回頭問Nate
要是帽子裡是三塊
你會怎麼做
Nate說
我喜歡Justin
可是我把錢拿走
全班都笑了
你看Justin做的事
他先跑到對方的位置上
看對方在那個當下會怎麼選
再走回來決定自己這一步
這個做法叫backward induction
中文叫逆向歸納
他的意思是
從最後一步開始
一步一步往回推
他很像走迷宮
你不從入口硬闖
你從出口倒著畫回來
錄一下就清楚了
巴拉克說
這是這學期最重要的一樣東西
可能是你在耶魯學到最有用的一樣
他還說
以後我點到你
你又剛好在睡覺
不知道問題是什麼
答案就是逆向歸納
那天下課前
波拉克馬上考大家一題
他指著一排同學說
你們現在都是餓了的獅子
最旁邊那位是一隻羊
規矩是
只有最大的獅子可以吃羊
可是他一吃飽就會睡著
睡著的時候
第二大的獅子就可以吃他
第二大的吃完也會睡著
第三大的就可以吃他
一路排下去
他問最大的那隻你吃不吃
那位同學說不吃
吃了我會被吃掉
這個直覺很正常
可是他只看了一步
我們從出口倒著走
最小的那隻獅子後面沒有人
他有機會就一定吃
所以倒數第二隻不敢吃
一吃就會被最小的吃掉
倒數第二隻不吃
倒數第三隻就可以放心吃
再往前一隻又不敢吃
吃不吃吃不吃
一直一直交替下去
Polak一路數回最大的那隻
答案是他其實可以吃
然後他笑著說
五分鐘前我才講
逆向歸納最重要
結果沒有人用
Polak說
那裡帽子是一個玩具
真正的遊戲叫借錢
第一個人是出錢的人
像專門投錢給新公司的創業投資公司
第二個人是拿錢去創業的人
錢進去以後
創業的人可以認真做
也可以隨便花
甚至帶著錢跑到墨西哥
你看剛剛的帽子
把三塊錢的大案子做成了
出錢的人跟創業的人
兩邊都比做一塊錢的小案子賺得多
兩個人都想要大案子
可是走不過去
出錢的人倒著算
就知道錢一多
對方拿走比認真做划算
所以不敢多放
這個問題叫Moral Hazard
中文叫道德風險
他的意思是
對方拿到東西以後
會有誘因去做對你不好的事
而你管不到
你買汽車保險也會碰到他
保險公司不讓你保全額
一定要你自己付一部分
因為全額保了
你可能就懶得鎖車門
回到借錢出錢的人
只好把案子做小
讓對方沒那麼想跑
兩個人都知道
大案子比較好
卻只能做小的
這是道德風險最難受的地方
要走到大案子
Polakun全班有什麼辦法
有人說立法
有人說分批給錢
HOLOC
都說好
可是各有限制
其中一位同學說
創業的人拿小頭
所以創業的人寧可把錢整包拿走
那就倒過來
讓創業的人多拿一點
多到把錢還回去比拿走更划算
這樣一改他就不跑了
大案子做得成
出錢的人分道的比例變小
可是餅變大了
他拿到的錢反而比做小案子多
這個做法叫incentive design
中文叫誘因設計
它的意思是
把規則改到對方自己想做對的事
不是去盯著他
是讓做對的事對他比較划算
不過誘因很難寫對
Polak拿自己開玩笑
他帶三歲的女兒去摘腹盆子
說好壓壞的可以當場吃
完好的帶回家
女兒宅一顆
轉頭跟他說壓壞了
放進嘴裡
再宅一顆又壓壞了
Paulak說
一個三歲小孩懂得道德風險
比教授還多
還有他大多手的辦法
擔保餅
你去借錢創業
銀行會要你壓一樣東西
Paulak說
對
大部分學生來說
那會是爸媽的房子
擔保餅怎麼幫上忙
很多人以為是銀行比較安心
就算你跑了
他還有一間房子
Paulak說
說銀行其實不想要你爸媽的房子
重點是你一跑
就會失去它
你把自己某一條路上的結果弄得很慘
對方倒著算
就敢借你大錢
自己的分數變低
最後反而拿得更多
這個做法有一個更大的名字
叫Commitment
中文叫承諾
它的意思是
先把自己的某些選項拿掉
讓對方相信你接下來只會那樣做
Polak舉了1066年的故事
諾曼人渡海打英格蘭
傳說指揮官William
上岸後把船燒了
士兵沒有退路
只能打
對面看到了就可能不敢衝
薩克遜人還是衝了
這個故事好聽
可是不完全是真的
重點是
承諾要有用
對方一定要知道
電影齊在博士裡
蘇聯造了一臺
一被攻擊就自動反擊的末日機器
卻忘了告訴美國人
承諾的想法
Pollock接著拿去看生意
他回到上集那兩家賣水的公司
上集他們是同時決定要做多少
這次改成一家先決定
另一家看到以後再決定
這個先後的版本
叫Stakeberg模型
先動的那家應該多做還是少做
很多人的第一個反應是
先動等於先把底牌亮出來
活動人家看到對方做很多隻能收回去
因為水一多價格就掉
兩家一起做多
大家都賺不到錢
所以先動的那家把產量拉高
逼對方少做
自己賺的比同時決定的時候多
你怎麼確定他一定賺的比較多
他本來就可以照就做
照就做就回到上集的結果
他選擇改
就代表改了比較賺
活動的那家做的少
價格又掉
賺的比以前少
倒是買水的人高興
兩家加起來做的水變多
價格變便宜
在這個遊戲裡先動是划算的
可是先動有一個前提
對方要相信你真的已經動了
plug one
那宣佈一下行不行
有位同學馬上說
不行
沒有可信的承諾
破了舉報紙當例子
兩家公司要進同一個小鎮辦報
那個鎮本來一份報紙都沒有
其中一家的老闆是Murdoch
他跳出來說
我要印很多份
對面憑什麼相信
花獎完可以改
到了真的要印的那一天
印少一點可能比較划算
他就會印少
所以光說沒用
要讓這句話算數
他得真的把印刷廠蓋起來
而且那間工廠
不能隨便當廢鐵賣掉
這種錢叫sum cost
中文叫沉沒成本
意思是花出去就拿不回來的錢
平常我們說
沉沒的成本是包袱
要學者放下
這裡剛好反過來
錢砸下去拿不回來
對面才相信你真的要做那麼多
說穿了
這跟燒船是同一件事
你把退路收掉
對面的算盤才會跟著變
同樣這兩家半報的公司
Polak再加一個轉折
Murdoch在對手的會議室裡
安插了一個人
會議開完
消息就傳回去
然後有人告訴對手
你們會議室裡有間諜
只是不知道是誰
你是對手你會怎麼做
一位同學說
他有一份假計劃
可是很難
合約總要真的錢
另一位同學給了更好的答案
不用假的
就把真的計劃給他看
你決定蓋一座大工廠
消息傳到Murdoch那裡
他現在就像剛剛後動的那一家
看到你做多了
只好縮小
你等於被推到先動的位置上
所以安插間諜的那一家
因為看得到你
反而虧了
條件是你要知道看得到
Polak把這幾堂課的例子
放在一起講
燒船讓選擇變少
擔保品讓分數變低
間諜讓一方知道的更多
結果都跟你想的不一樣
因為他們改變了對面的做法
一個人自己做決定的時候
選擇多
知道多
一定不會吃虧
可是在賽局裡都不一定
這幾段聽下來
你可能會覺得
先動總是比較好
Polax最怕的就是這種結論
他說機場書店裡
常有一種書
封面燙金
寫著凡事要先動
才有先動者優勢
這句話聽起來很對
所以很危險
你個人猜拳
你想先出還是後出
當然後出
公司要買一批新設備
讓別人先買
看好不好
不用再跟
還有一種是
就是兩邊都沒有優勢
小時候跟兄弟姐妹分蛋糕
一個人切另一個人先挑
誰都佔不到便宜所以才公平
接著Paulak請兩位同學上臺玩Nim
兩堆石頭輪流拿
每次只能從一堆拿
拿幾顆都行
拿到最後一顆的人贏
玩了兩輪臺下有人說出訣竅
把兩堆弄成一樣多
之後對方在一堆拿幾顆
你就在另一堆拿一樣多
所以兩堆一開始不一樣多
先動的人贏
一樣多後動的人贏
那天Paulak故意擺成不一樣多
因為先上臺的同學剛好生日
Nim最有意思的地方不是誰贏
是石頭一擺上桌 誰會贏就定了
Polak說 這件事可以講得更大
他有一個名字 叫Zermelo定理
定理說 只要一場遊戲滿足幾個條件
他就一定有答案
兩個人輪流走
每個人輪到的時候
都看得到前面發生的每一步
而且遊戲不會沒完沒了
那結果只有三種
先手有辦法一定贏
先手有辦法至少合局
或者後手有辦法一定贏
Nimh是第一種或第三種
看石頭怎麼擺
景緻遊戲是第二種
兩邊都不出錯 就是合局
西洋棋也滿足這些條件
走法多到數不完
可是棋規會逼他結束
所以西洋棋一定有答案
證明的方法
就是我們的迷宮
從出口一格一格倒著推回來
可是這個定理有一個尷尬的地方
他只說答案存在
不告訴你答案是什麼
我們到今天還不知道
白棋到底是一定贏
還是隻能合局
知道有答案
跟知道答案是兩回事
倒著算的時候
有一件事很容易被忽略
在有先後順序的遊戲裡
Paulak說
一套策略
是一份完整的計劃
每一個你可能輪到的地方
你會怎麼做
都要寫下來
連你根本走不到的地方也要寫
拿帽子來說
第二個人的策略不能只寫看到1塊怎麼辦
還要寫看到0元怎麼辦
看到3塊怎麼辦
為什麼要寫走不到的地方
因為別人算你的時候用的就是那些地方
第一個人會先想
我放3塊你會怎麼回
再決定放多少
每一發生的那些路
正是別人判斷你的依據
麻煩也在這裡
如果只是照上級的方法
機械裡去找納許均衡
你會找到一些怪答案
某個人在走不到的地方寫了很蠢的一步
照樣成立
因為反正走不到
寫什麼都不會被抓到
這一段第一次聽有點抽象
我自己也是看了下一個例子才懂
你還記得夜市那個老攤子跟新攤子嗎
Polak在課堂上講的是同一件事
一個市場裡只有一家老店
獨佔的時候賺最多
一家新店想進來
新店進來
老店可以跟他和平分
兩家各賺一份
也可以降價拼到底
老店一毛都賺不到
新店還倒賠
老店先放話
你趕進來
我就跟你拼
新店相信了就不進來
老店繼續自己一家賺
你一次都不用真的拼
上甲的方法說
這也是一族納許均衡
可是你看那句重話
正好寫在一個走不到的地方
用逆向歸納走一次
我們先走到最後一步
新店已經進來了
這時候拼下去老店自己也一毛都賺不到和平分還有一份
所以到了那一刻他不會拼
這種話叫non-credible threat
中文叫不可信的威脅
他的意思是
說了出口
到了關頭卻不會做的話
Paulak說你真的要去做一套作業系統
Bill Gates
可能會派人跟你講幾句話
可是那幾句話本身沒有分量
可是現實裡老店真的會拼
Paulak下一堂課就把這件事演出來
他請一位助教LA當披薩店老闆
在十個城鎮各開一家店
再請10位同學當想進場的新店
一個城鎮一位
照順序來
每個人先報上家鄉
邁阿密、馬迪遜、橋港、聖路易
一個一個變成地圖上的點
第一位
Isabella說進
Elle說拼
她賠了100萬
第二位看到了
說不進
接下來好幾位都不進
一直到第七位跟第八位
又有人趕進
Elle照樣拼
兩個人也都賠了
最後兩位又不敢進了
你看Elle做的事
第一場
她明明也虧
還是要拼
因為這一場不是拼給眼前這個人看的
他用前面幾場的虧損
換後面幾場的安靜
Polak最後問Al
要是第十位進來
你會怎麼做
Al說我不會拼
Al最後那句話
正好是逆向圭娜的起點
我們從出口倒著走
第十個層次後面沒有下一個
在那裡拼
已經沒有人要看
所以他不會拼
第十位可以放心進
那第九場呢
Al在第九場拼得再兇
也擋不住第十位
反正第十位一定會進
所以第九場拼了也白拼
他也不會拼
第九位也該進
一路倒著推回來
每一場都一樣
每一位都該進
老店一個都擋不住
可是我們剛剛親眼看到
他擋住了好幾個
理論跟教室裡發生的事
完全對不上
這個問題叫Chain Store Paradox
中文叫連鎖店悖論
他的意思是
一步一步都推得通
推出來的結論
卻跟我們看到的現實對不上
提出他的是Selten
他後來拿了諾貝爾經濟學獎
那問題出在哪裡
Polak補了一樣很小的東西
1%的懷疑
假設大家心裡覺得
Li有1%的機會
是一個真的愛打架的人
賠錢也要拼
他就是喜歡
只有一個城鎮的話這1%沒什麼用
第一位還是會進
幾乎可以確定L會讓
可是死個城鎮就不一樣了
L在第一場拼了
大家心裡那個機率就往上跳
第二場再拼又跳一次
後面的人就不敢賭了
再往下想一層
既然看起來愛打架這麼有用
一個完全清醒的A類也會故意裝成愛打架的樣子
Polak還補了一個細節
要是每個清醒的老闆都一定會裝
大家就看不出誰是真的
倒著推又會從後面垮掉
所以真正的答案是清醒的老闆有時候拼有時候不拼
又回到了第一部分的混合策略
還記得約會那一段嗎
混合可以是別人心裡對你的猜測
名聲
就是住在別人心裡的那個猜測
這個道理在生活裡到處都是
你身邊有沒有那種脾氣比較急的朋友
一群人挑電影
點餐
玩遊戲選編
最後常常照他的意思走
不是他比較有道理
是大家怕他翻臉
先讓他一步
Polak還說
他可能根本沒那麼容易生氣
只是知道這樣比較容易拿到他要的
他在做的就是剛剛那個披薩店老闆
同一個道理
也解釋了那句很冷的話
不跟綁架的人談條件
這一次談了眼前的人質可能得救
可是不談
是說給以後的人聽的
綁了也沒有用
名聲也不止兇這一種
醫生跟會計師靠的是另一種名聲
這個人會說實話
會計師事務所Arthur Anderson
在安龍公司爆出做假賬的醜聞之後
很快就收掉了
他靠的那樣東西不見了
Polak說
有一年他在課堂上舉這個例子
臺下剛好坐著Arthur Anderson三世
兇的名聲讓人不敢惹你
誠實的名聲讓人願意信你
兩種都是靠前面一次一次做到
才住進別人心裡的
最後
我們回到開場那兩塊石海綿
Polak請兩位美式足球隊的同學上臺
一人一塊
站在走道兩端輪流做選擇
輪到你的時候
你可以把海綿丟出去
丟中就贏
也可以往前走一步
離得越近
當然越容易丟中
關鍵規則只有一條
海綿丟出去就沒了
撿不回來
所以你一丟不中
對方就能慢慢走到你面前
把海綿輕輕放在你頭上
這場遊戲的問題
不是說什麼
大家都知道要丟
問題是什麼時候丟
Polak問全班
準投好的人會先丟
還是準頭差的人會先丟
有人說準的先丟命中率高
有人說差的先丟
要搶在被丟中之前
可是準的也會想
差的可能先搶
那我要更早
你想一層對方就想兩層
那天很多人乾脆棄權
Paul Lark說
這種問題不止在教室裡
自行車賽
什麼時候從大隊裡衝出去
兩家公司什麼時候推出新產品
都是同一種問題
這一題最後是全班一起解出來的
用的是兩把老工具
第一把
假設我知道你明天不會丟
我今天就不該丟
因為我明天離你更近更容易中
第二把
假設我知道你明天會丟
我要比的是兩件事
我今天丟中的幾率
跟你明天丟不中的幾率
你明天丟不中我就贏了
所以這兩個要拿來比
把它整理一下
就是一條很好記的規則
我今天丟中的幾率
加上你明天丟中的幾率
只要加起來超過億
我就該丟
離得很遠的時候
兩個人都不準
這個和小於一
不管對方明天丟不丟
今天都該往前走
一步一步走進
總有一步
這個和第一次超過億
怎麼知道到了那一步
對方明天一定會丟
從出口倒著走
貼在一起的時候一定丟
退一步也該丟
一路退回來都是丟
所以答案是
第一次超過億的那一步
輪到誰誰就丟
18世紀的軍隊有一句話
等你看見對方的眼白在開槍
說的就是這一步
規則寫在黑板上
很簡單
可是Paul Lark說
這個遊戲他玩了很多年
不管在大學部還是商學院
同學幾乎都丟得太早
然後沒中
那天也一樣
兩組都是有人先丟
都沒中
照理說
準投有好有壞
丟中的應該有一半左右
他猜了兩個原因
一個是人常常對自己太有信心
另一個他說是美國人的習慣
從小被教要主動
要掌握自己的命運
運動員比賽結束接受訪問
最愛講這句
他問那些丟太早的同學為什麼
他們說至少我倒下之前有揮過拳
Paul Lack說
人生的目標不是倒下之前揮過拳
是不要倒下
他還提醒一件事
就算對面是一個完全不懂這套的人
你也不該在那一步之前丟
因為在那之前
不管對方怎麼做
往前走都比較好
有時候等就是一種策略
我們把第三部分也收起來
第三個問題是
對方看得到你出手
看完才懂
你那一步還划算嗎
這時候最有用的方法
叫逆向歸納
先站到最後一步
看那個人到時候會怎麼選
再一步一步倒著走回來
就像從迷宮的出口
畫回入口
這個方法幫我們看懂了三件事
第一
你說的話要算數
得是走到那一步
對你還划算
所以要蓋工廠
要燒船
要壓房子
把退路收掉
而且要讓對方看見
第二
選擇少一點
分數低一點
甚至被人看光
有時候反而幫了你
因為對面會跟著改
第三
第三,民生就是住在別人心裡的猜測
前面付的代價
換到後面的安靜
而且只要一點點懷疑就夠
連最後那兩塊海綿也是一樣
不是越找越好
是算到那一步才出手
我們回到開場那個問題
你想好的那一步等別人反應過來以後還划算嗎
這巴唐克給了三個答案
其實說的是同一件事
對方會猜你的時候你不能被讀出來
而且你怎麼混是對面的分數決定的
一代一代換人的時候
留下來的是外人進來
佔不到便宜的做法
只是他不一定好
對方看得到你的時候
你說的每一步
都要走到那一刻
對你還划算
才算數
所以這一集的答案是
難的不是眼前划算
是長期划算
下集
Polak會從口袋裡
拿出一張真的一塊錢
走到講臺
讓兩個同學來分
從那一開始
他要問的是
當你根本看不到
對方心裡那件事的時候
你還能不能算
最後問你一個問題
你有沒有為了
讓別人相信你是認真的
故意把自己的退路收掉過
後來對方有沒有因此改變
留言告訴我
喜歡這種
把公開課講清楚的內容
也可以訂閱AI Notebook
我是Jim
我們下次見